I think about Ratatouille every time I cook.
Even.
If I'm just adding salt to pasta water,
that movie captures how cooking feels or at least how I want it to feel.
And also how I want it to taste.
There are some movies and TV shows that stick with you long after you've
finished them. And you just can't help, but obsess,
no matter how pretentious you usually try to be the movies and TV I
cherish the most are almost always the ones that stick with me in some unusual
way. This past summer,
my roommates and I realized we had a rodent infestation in our house.
And during the ensuing chaos of putting up traps,
clogging holes with steel wool,
and always feeling slightly uncomfortable on our ground floor,
a particular show from 2019 always came to mind.
And that's when I realized, I now think about Chernobyl.
Every time a disaster happens in my life,
no matter how small that show captured a feeling I hadn't seen anywhere else,
but one that I experienced all the time, Chernobyl portrays crisis,
how it actually happens in real life.
American disaster movies are full of heroes, individuals exercising.
The free will to do what they think is right.
It's a fantasy that goes all the way back to spaghetti westerns the story that
the individual can write every wrong by challenging their fo to a showdown or by
blowing up the enemy spaceship. But Chernobyl is anti story.
The disaster itself has no spectacle. It literally happens in the background.
There's no honor in what the Soviets had to do. It's scary. It's disturbing.
It's anti heroic in Chernobyl.
The potential volunteers quickly realize they're being asked to participate in a
suicide mission,
but the nervous recruits don't get a riveting speech from a president standing
in between fighter jets shot at a low angle that ends in everybody cheering and
celebrating.
They get this, they'll do it. If it goes, it must be done.
There's no rallying cry just like a real life disaster.
No one is there to make them a hero and their sacrifice doesn't receive any
spectacle or sense of triumph. In fact,
their dangerous task is in part shot in complete darkness.
Chernobyl gave me something. I didn't know I needed,
I hadn't realized how much I would enjoy a show that gave me such a strong and
realistic alternative to the traditional and fantastical American approach to
disaster storytelling.
I can't help,
but feel like I missed out on something special by not seeing 2001,
a space Odyssey. When it came out in theaters.
It's not my favorite movie of all time,
but I'll always appreciate how bold and different it is.
Especially for a 1968 release.
Sometimes I feel like the golden era of filmmaking has already happened.
Like I missed a party that I would have really enjoyed when he grew up with a
cynical dad showing you films from a bygone era.
It's hard not to think that way.
Will I ever get to sit in a theater and experience something like one of
Kubrick's classics,
but then this fall I saw a film that's probably as close as I'm going to get.
The lighthouse is a complete trip into madness.
Following in the footsteps of atmospheric thrillers, like the shining,
it feels unsettling and hypnotic. And the dialogue by writer,
director Eggers elevates the film beyond reality and into the mythic.
Jordan paella deaths with treble dread make the ocean
cave sharp bed.
Epic has 2001. And as oddly mystical as the shining,
but this time there's a postmodern absurdity to it that makes it uniquely suited
to the time we live in.
It's a genuinely hilarious film, but anytime something funny happens,
you can barely tell if you're laughing because it's actually funny or because
it's so tense, which in turn leads to more tension in one scene,
Winslow played by Robert Pattinson simply tells wake played by Willem Defoe.
He doesn't like his cooking and wake response with.
Try Jenna hark.
The severity of his threat in proportion to Winslow's drunken.
And mission is so absurd that it's instantly funny,
but it also serves the purpose.
It shows us Wake's dangerous sensitivity and his propensity to manipulate others
into saying and doing what he wants. The scene sets the film in this unsettling,
no man's land between threat and hilarity. That feels both old-timey and modern.
Kubrick's.
Films were funny and had moments of absurdity.
But if they were as absurd as the lighthouse,
I think audiences and critics from the sixties and seventies wouldn't have
understood it To put it this way.
The shining never would have worked in 1980. If it had fart jokes,
the lighthouse builds on what made these films innovative for their time,
but elevates new ideas that work particularly well for 2019. Honestly,
a lot of this movie feels like a meme.
Why Jewish beans don't me?
It's dark. It's silly. It's absurd.
And it is entirely unashamedly and unequivocally weird.
This film about two stranded trunk,
farting lighthouse keepers shot on lenses from the turn of the century and
presented in a one by 19 by one black and white format sticks out like a sore
thumb in the era of the cinematic universe.
But I think it proves that there will always be room for weird.
God Fox. Good.
My go-to romantic comedy was always 500 days of summer.
We saw a lot of myself in Tom Hansen.
He's romantic to a fault and his misguided expectations teach him how to better
handle future relationships. Overall,
the film portrays his missteps in a pretty sympathetic light after all he is a
hopeless romantic,
is it so bad that he just wants to be with the woman he loves from his point of
view, his actions seem justified,
but I've always felt that we missed a part of the story.
We only see the relationship through Tom.
How do you think this story would be told from summer's point of view?
I think it would look a little more like this.
[Inaudible].
I can't stop thinking about Fleabag because to my horror,
I saw a piece of myself in her boyfriends.
And from her point of view, their romanticism is not justified sympathetic.
It's actually pretty lame and hilarious before watching this show,
I hadn't seen with my own eyes,
the struggle women have navigating male egos in their dads, their coworkers,
or their partners, older men were never allowed to express how they feel.
So they're doomed to a life of poor emotional communication.
I want to say
very much.
For the younger generation of men that finally feel comfortable expressing
themselves. They're still extremely clumsy and fragile.
The priest in season two is a perfect counterpoint to this fragile male
character in season one, by becoming a priest,
he is in a way escape to the sexual and fraternal struggles. Men usually face.
Maybe that's partially why he's so appealing to Fleabag.
I can't stop thinking about this show because I was shocked to see myself in
pathetic male characters. And I realized I owed my girlfriend a few apologies,
Difficult to define what these works of art have in common.
But I do think they all had a major directorial vision.
Each creator shared a story they personally understood,
and this subject matter expertise made their work great.
The beauty of the internet is that we have instant access to experts in their
fields. If we want to learn something,
if you want to learn the best ways to shoot a short documentary, for example,
you can watch a class on that exact topic by Academy award nominated director,
Elaine Sheldon on Skillshare. Skillshare is huge catalog of classes on film,
web development.
And marketing means that you can learn from the experts themselves,
which is my go-to strategy for tackling a new topic.
Right now you can get two months of Skillshare for free with our link,
click the link in the description to help support this channel and get two
months of unlimited access to thousands of classes for free.
Or you can buy Skillshare annually for less than $10 a month.
And as always thanks to our patrons who make this channel possible.
Thanks for watching.